hi mystery recapped here today I'm going
to explain a Norwegian historical drama
film called the 12th man spoilers ahead
watch out and take care
[Music]
during the second world war the ruthless
Nazis attacked Norway and took control
of it in the process they killed
hundreds of civilians obliterated the
cities and committed other inhumane war
crimes they also looted the country of
its valuable resources making themselves
even stronger hence with each passing
day the Allies came under immense
pressure knowing that they could be next
following this we are taken to the year
1943 in Scotland a bunch of Norwegian
men are being trained by the Royal
British Army the plan is to form a
special group which can sneak inside
occupied Norway and Destroy German
strongholds like military bases and
airports after weeks of rigorous
training 12 men are finally selected
they are sent off via a ship with all
the necessary arrangements however at
the end of the mission only one returns
all of his friends have been killed
brutally the scene then cuts to three
months earlier where the 12 men have
come under attack the Germans spotted
them from afar and destroyed their ship
11 of them are immediately up
apprehended but the final one Jan
balzarud manages to hide shortly after
he makes a run for it and the Germans
finally notice him they fire several
bullets at him until one of them strikes
yawn in his toe soon there is blood
everywhere and the Germans follow it to
track the fugitive however Jan still
manages to get away after hours of
running he arrives near a lake at night
the temperature is freezing and Jan very
well knows that he can die of a cardiac
arrest but since the Germans are
approaching he decides to take the risk
Yan slowly gets inside the freezing cold
water and swims away seconds later the
Germans arrive with flare guns and
torches they search the entire area but
find no signs of The Fugitive hence the
general deduces the yawn has already
died inside the lake and leaves with his
men later a superior Nazi officer Kurt
staga arrives to inspect the 12
Norwegian soldiers when he finds only 11
he asks the general about it and the
latter asserts that the 12th one died
inside a lake however Kurt is not going
to believe it until and unless he finds
a body so he orders his men to search
the entire area and find dietzforth man
elsewhere Jan emerges from the lake but
his condition has become very critical
his face and other body parts have been
covered in ice despite this the UN
continues moving forward until he comes
across a couple of locals luckily the
two turn out to be good people and they
immediately escort yawn to their home
there they provide him with food and
warm clothes and also treat his wounds
Yan is really lucky to be alive because
if he had stayed a few more hours in the
snow he would have died of hypothermia
on the other hand Kurt interrogates the
11 men for information about their
plants but no one speaks a word as a
result he punishes them severely and
even executes some of them Kurt is also
adamant on finding the 12th man but he
firstly wants to check if it is even
possible to cross the freezing Lake Kurt
himself volunteers and immerses himself
inside the insanely Cold Lake he stays
there for 20 long minutes and 5 finally
comes to the conclusion that one can
definitely survive this Lake then he
gets hypothermia and dies
meanwhile after Yan gets better he sets
it to help his friends a kind Local Rose
him across the lake and gives him some
supplies Jan who has no idea where he is
stumbles across a cottage where an old
lady lives the two chat for a while and
become Fast Friends the old lady even
treats his feet and gives him the
address of someone who can help him
after a while John thanks her and
departs he is once again back in the
cold Wilderness where nothing but snow
is visible for as far as the eye can see
however with the hopes of seeing his
friends again Jan continues walking that
evening he finally arrives at the
address the old lady gave him the
inhabitants of the house are a couple
and their loving daughter after Jan
explains his story the three immediately
welcome him home and provide him with
good food one day the wife approaches
Yan with some bad news she mentions that
one of her friends is a nurse who works
at the local hospital and in that same
Hospital several of yawn's friends have
been kept they have been mistreated and
beaten up to the point that they have
gone insane while some have already died
hearing this neon breaks down in tears
and decides to abandon his plan of
rescuing his friends instead he wants to
go to neutral Sweden as there the
Germans can't harm him elsewhere when
Kurt fails to extract any information
out of the Norwegians he shoots all of
them dead later one of the officers
approaches him and explains that they
have searched all the houses in the area
but couldn't find the 12th man he then
requests to call off the search
operations and make a report that they
killed all 12 Norwegian soldiers however
Kurt refuses saying he doesn't want to
lie to Hitler elsewhere Jan has arrived
at a fisherman's house as per the
earlier family's instructions on his
boat the fisherman gives him a ride as
far as he can on the way they have a
good conversation about the current
affairs of the country the fisherman
then whips out a newspaper and showcases
an article highlighting Kurt staga it
turns out Kurt is one of the fiercest
Nazi generals who has won numerous
medals for his gallantry he has a record
of tracking down and apprehending all
the prisoners he has gone after now Kurt
is on the hunt for yawn and he is taking
the matter very seriously in the next
scene the boat finally arrives at the
shore the fisherman hands you on some
food water and even a pair of skis
before departing following this Eon puts
on the skis and continues his journey he
goes through dense forests and high
hills until he comes across a small
village unfortunately there are a few
Germans in the area and Kurt is one of
them as Jan tries going past them he
suddenly trips and falls soon Kurt
approaches him and stares into his eyes
menacingly it appears as if the
Norwegian is going to be apprehended but
Kurt simply makes fun of his skiing
abilities and lets him go however after
a few minutes it finally Dawns on Kurt
that the skier might have been The
Fugitive they are looking for hence
without wasting any time he orders his
men to call for backup shortly after a
luftwaffa aircraft is dispatched and it
immediately tracks yawn the aircraft
then fires several rounds of bullets but
none of them hit their target just then
a massive Avalanche occurs and despite
yon trying his best to escape he is
caught in the snow and buried because of
this the aircraft also leaves after
several hours Jan comes out of the snow
he is in a very horrible condition his
face is bleeding profusely because of
severe frostbite his nails have fallen
off and even his eyes are injured at
first glance it appears as if a zombie
has risen from the snow despite all of
this Yan still manages to get up his
body may be bruised and battered but the
willpower inside of him is stronger than
ever hence he slowly moves through the
white Wasteland hoping he can find help
on the other hand Kurt learns about the
Avalanche but he is still sure that Jan
is alive so he sends some soldiers to
the location by this time Yawn is long
gone but his belongings have been left
behind the soldiers find his clothes a
map and also his pair of skis when Kirk
gets to know of this he initiates a
massive Manhunt to find the escaped
fugitive the soldiers go from door to
door and ask all the families in the
area if they have seen yon they also
threatened to kill those who were found
assisting the perpetrator meanwhile a
borderline lifeless yawn somehow manages
to reach the nearby Village where a
brother sister Duo Marius and gudron
immediately assist him they patch up his
wounds give him warm clothes and also
manage a place for him to hide as the
Germans are frequently inspecting the
area after a long week hyon regains some
of his strength and is ready to depart
but since he cannot walk due to severe
frostbite the siblings and some other
locals put him in a sledge and drop him
in a nearby Cottage there Jan will have
to live alone for some days until
someone comes to pick him up the first
few days go by easily but then he starts
hallucinating in most of his nightmares
Jan sees himself being apprehended by
the Germans he also finds himself
dancing to a beautiful song one day when
he checks his feet he finds most of his
fingers infected by gangrene realizing
that the disease will spread if not
treated soon Jan decides to carry out a
tough decision he picks up a knife and
slices some of his infected fingers
causing himself excruciating pain
however because of this decision his
life is saved after nine long days
Marius finally arrives with his group
and wakes yawn up together they load him
on a sledge and start pulling him uphill
later they arrive at another checkpoint
and hide him under a large Rock before
leaving Marius promises Tian that a man
will pick him up soon and take him
across the border to Sweden
unfortunately even after several hours
no one comes day turns into night and
the temperature drops well below
negative 20 degrees Yan is shivering
profusely and it appears as if he is
finally going to bite the dust in the
next scene Marius and goodrunner at home
discussing if Jan has already crossed
the border just then a man approaches
them anxiously he is the same man who is
supposed to pick up yawn four days ago
when the siblings asked what happened
the man mentions that he searched
everywhere around the mountain but
couldn't find Yan this is when Marius
realizes that he and his group actually
left Yan on the wrong Mountain wasting
no time he heads to the subtle location
with one of his friends and digs yawn
out of the thick snow the latter appears
to be lifeless but soon he starts moving
even after being deprived of food and
water for several days Jan has managed
to survive whilst being submerged in the
thick snow Marius feeds him some hot
soup and requests him to hang on for
just a few more hours Marius has nothing
to worry about the guy's clearly
Invincible in no time a group of men
arrive with sludges and take him away
they travel for hours along the desolate
terrain but since Ian has become
considerably weak they decide to take
shelter inside a cave Yan is furious
with the idea as he fears the Germans
might catch up to them he is also scared
that he will put the lives of these men
in danger however the leader of the
Sledge group assures him that they are
safe following this the group starts
taking care of yawn from time to time
they also cut off the infected parts of
his feet so that the gangrene doesn't
spread six days pass by and when Jan
finally recovers some of his health the
group decides to leave this time they
employ the help of thousands of rain
reindeer because right near the border
there is a German Outpost the plan is to
crowd the area so that Eon goes
unnoticed after a while the entire group
sets out and Jan is loaded on a sled
which is pulled by the alpha reindeer of
the herd in no time they approached the
Border prompting the Germans to be on
high alert they quickly bring out their
binoculars and look for yawn but fail to
find him in the crowd the plan seems to
be working for the group but just then
the ropes holding eon's Sledge snap
resulting in a painful accident the
Germans also noticed him and immediately
start firing but using the last of his
strength Yan manages to hide behind a
rock now it is just a matter of time
before he is found so with no options
left Yan brings out his gun and prepares
to commit the unthinkable however right
before he can do it the alpha reindeer
approaches him Rudolph you son of a
[ __ ] this reinvigorates yawn's purpose
to live so he drops his gun and starts
tying the Rope around his hands then he
fires his gun into the sky startling the
reindeer so badly that it starts running
with all of its might the two go right
asked the Germans avoiding all of their
bullets then a miracle happens the
reindeer manages to take Ian across the
border to Sweden Jan is over the moon
and he starts screaming like a maniac
while the Germans are distraught as they
have no jurisdiction on the other side
they immediately call Kurt and inform
him about it and the latter cannot
believe that he has failed for the first
time in his life cut to three months
later Jan has returned to Scotland he is
mostly recovered from his physical
injuries but the mental trauma still
persists one day during a military
function he slowly limps towards his
General and hands him his report Jan is
considered a hero for escaping the Nazis
and retrieving information which turned
out to be vital in liberating Norway in
1945 the war ended and Kurt Saga was
executed in 1947 for the atrocities he
took part in Marius got married and had
five children while gudron lived with
her boyfriend happily Yan was awarded
with several bravery Awards but he
credits all the brave men women and even
the reindeer who helped him during the
63 hellish days Jan lived a long and
peaceful life with his family in Norway
until he died in 1988 but his death was
faked he actually went on to become
Santa Claus subscribe for more videos
like this turn on notifications and
leave a like to help the channel out
thank you for watching